Hello world,
it's Saroj and if you only have a little
bit of data can you still learn from it?
We're going to build a model that learns
to classify images using a very small
dataset for training. The pointing
is still very much a dark heart.
It's an emerging practice in the world
of machine learning that isn't well
understood even by those
pushing the state of the art,
which is exciting because it means that
there's so much potential for discovery
and it's not just one algorithm. It's
a collection of them. Recurrent Nets,
convolutional nets, restricted
ultimate machines, Barbra Streisand.
These are all networks that can
recognize patterns in the world and they
themselves have shared patterns.
One shared pattern is that they
all use a hierarchy of layers.
The other is using differentiable
layers so that we can use gradient based
optimization to improve their prediction.
Design patterns are nothing
new in computer science.
There are many books on design patterns
for topics like object oriented
programming and user interfaces.
When it comes to deep learning,
there's not really a definitive
design pattern guide.
We're all kind of figuring it
out collectively right now.
You might glaze over a deep learning
paper and assume that there is some solid
mathematical foundation behind what the
researchers attempted because you see
all sorts of equations for things like
Hilbert spaces and measure theory.
But the reality is that our collective
understanding is still pretty minimal.
Theories are often formulated because
they are mathematically convenient.
For example, the dossier and
distribution is ubiquitous,
not because it's some divine construct
that the universe has bestowed on us,
but because it's
mathematically convenient.
So defining standard design patterns for
pattern recognition networks is a field
right for discovery.
In the context of machine learning,
we can call it metal learning
or learning to learn.
Can we design a system that
learns how best to learn? That is.
It learns how to perform
well at an immediate task
in the short term and in the
longterm it learns a common
structure across many tasks.
We see metal level constructs in nature
all the time. DNA is a great example.
It carries the instructions,
the blueprint to create learning
systems that can expire our brains,
but it acts as longterm memory by
transcending death. Just like Oracle.
As long as there is a mechanism for
memory and one to alter behavior based on
that memory and that mechanism can
serve as a metal level construct.
In the past few months,
there have been several papers on
metal learning that had been published,
but I want to talk about one that uses
metal learning as a tool to solve another
task.
One shot learning the goal of learning
from one or only a few data points.
This is what we should be aiming for.
Since GPU costs are too damn ha,
they used a modified version of a
model called a neural Turing machine.
The learned declassified character
images with just a few examples.
The mind first raise up the idea of
Mtms in 2014 it contains two components.
The first is a neural network that
we call the controller and the other,
it's a memory bank. The controller
takes vectors as inputs and outputs,
vectors as well,
just like all neural nets.
But what makes it special is that it
also interacts with a memory matrix using
read and write operations. This is where
the Turing machine analogy comes from,
not just cause it sounds dope,
but because a turning machine manipulates
symbols on a strip of tape according
to a table of rules.
It's like having a working memory for a
brain and network learns how best to use
its memory when learning a solution to
a given problem. For the controller,
they use an LSTM recurrent network.
Since it's internal state is a function
of the current state and the input to
the system. It can perform
context dependent computation.
So a signal at a current time step can
influence the network's behavior later on.
We need all the components including
the memory store to be differentiable so
that we can incrementally update their
values during training. To achieve this,
they added an attention mechanism so
that each read and write operation
interacts to a tuneable degree
with all the elements in memory.
Rather than addressing a single element
like a normal touring machine would.
Each row in the memory matrix
represents a memory location.
Read and write heads use a weighting
vector with a component for each location.
So if there are 10 memory locations and
the weighting vector with just one value
at index,
three would focus the attention of the
memory operation on location three but a
weighting vector like this spreads its
attention to the memory across multiple
locations.
A re operation is just a combination of
the memory matrix and weighting vector.
A write operation though has two parts
on a race operation than an ad operation.
Way these read and write heads are
produced is by combining two memory
addressing mechanisms.
The first is content based.
We focus on locations based
on the similarity between
their current values and
the controllers emitted values.
The second is location based.
It puts silicates iterations across
locations of the memory and random access
jump,
right?
So
the authors of our one shot
learning paper knew that Mtms,
we're a subset of memory augmented neural
networks and they saw the potential to
improve on it so that they could
learn from just a little data.
They discovered that using a pure content
based memory writer instead of content
plus location,
let them do just this.
That's because there's a trade off
when training man s more complex.
The memory mechanism,
the more training the controller requires,
the data set has 1600 separate classes
and only a few examples per class.
Perfect for one shot learning,
they randomly five classes and randomly
assigned each class a label between one
and five so the model gets shown.
An instance of a class tries to classify
it and it gets informed of what the
correct label is.
We'll only need tensorflow and num Pi for
our model will first define our memory
bank and internalizing each of
the variables that make it up.
Then we can define our controller.
A feedforward neural network will define
each set of weights and biases layer by
layer until we've
reached the output layer.
We can define the interaction that
happens between both components under the
step function, which is called
every time step. During training,
just like with a regular NTM,
we read a vector from memory that is a
linear combination of it's rose scaled,
a normalized wait vector
for the given input x.
The read vector will produce a key.
We compare each key against each row in
memory using the cosine similarity as a
measure.
This produces the read wait vector,
which tells us how much each row should
contribute to the linear combination.
The difference here is that there is no
extra perimeter to control the read wait
vectors concentration to write to memory.
The controller interpolate between writing
to the most recently read memory rose
and writing to the least
used memory recipes.
Using the read wait vector at a previous
time step and the weight vector that
captures the least used memory location.
The controller combines the two using
a scalar parameter and the sigmoid
function to create a right wait vector.
Each row in memory is then updated using
the right way vector and the key issued
by the controller.
The model eventually returns the
probabilities for each class as a Vectra.
After we've initialize
our tensorflow session,
we use gradient descent via
Adam to optimize our network.
For every image labeled pair
we feed in via a dictionary.
We'll print out our results
iteratively after training.
We can test it out on some different
recognizable characters and notice how the
accuracy is surprisingly good.
Normally training time would take
a lot longer for similar results.
These results are very promising for
lunch and learning. That's all it takes.
Some training folks.
Let's get down to brass tacks.
A metal learning system learns how to
perform well at an immediate task and also
learns a common structure
across many tasks. Memory,
augmented neural networks like the neural
Turing machine use a controller and an
external memory store to perform metal
learning and metal learning can be a way
to achieve one shot learning, which means
learning from one or a few examples.
This week's coding challenge is to use
a memory augmented network to learn to
classify two classes of animals.
He tells her and the read me get humbling.
It's going to comments and winners
will be announced in one week,
and although this is the
last video for this course,
I'm still just getting started.
Please subscribe for more programming
videos and for now I've got to go
celebrate.
So thanks for watching.